hi welcome to another cold fusion video
wirecard was once the model of tech
startups in germany
last year they were listed on the german
equivalent of the dow jones among the
top 30 companies
wirecard wasn't just big there were also
innovators
the company had been dubbed among the
top 100 most innovative growth companies
by forbes
and the company's promotional material
wanted you to know that
buzzwords like reimagining reinventing
and innovation were often used
so how in the space of just nine days
did y card's share price
go from 100 euros a share to less than
two euros a share
and how did the company end up in a
place where they're filing for
insolvency
and owe creditors 4 billion us dollars
the answer lies in the fact that 2
billion us dollars is missing
the equivalent of the entire company's
operating profit
wirecard hid the fraud from financial
and regulatory institutions
auditors and the government this was a
tale of lies
accounting manipulation hacking attacks
on journalists
an arrested former ceo and a missing
executive
in this episode we'll take a look at the
enron of europe
wirecard you are watching
tell fusion tv
[Music]
wirecard was founded in 1999 in a
suburban munich germany
the firm provided online payment
services acting as an
intermediary between consumers and
producers online
the money transfers were fast safe and
convenient
riding off the back of the e-commerce
boom the company became a giant
in the space of five years they saw its
share price increased tenfold
ceo at the time marcus braun became a
billionaire by earning seven percent of
the shares
by 2005 they had developed a core
business in managing the payments of
online gambling and adult content
despite shady beginnings through a
series of acquisitions
they moved into banking and were even
issuing their own credit cards
after taking over the reigns in 2002
only three years after the company was
founded
marcus braun had global ambitions for
the company
in a company christmas party in 2009 he
stated that english
would now become the company's official
language this was to reflect
its global ambitions however according
to a former staff member
this drew awkward reactions as only half
of the staff at the time spoke english
and many of them couldn't understand
what braun was even saying
as the company became more successful
braun edged billionaire status
he appeared to exhibit the image of what
a tech leader should look like
speaking at tech conferences he began
sporting the classic black turtleneck
after the theronos episode i find it
funny how it's becoming a theme for
frauds to try and imitate steve jobs
regardless braun had every reason to
believe that he was on the same
trajectory as jobs
having grown the company to a top 30
stock in germany it made wirecard a rare
european
tech success story however braun himself
seemed to be somewhat disjointed from
the rest of the company
he created a barrier between himself and
most of the company
he worked on a floor only accessible by
senior members
leaving work meant getting on an
elevator directly to a car park where a
chauffeur
waited for him in a mercedes he'll be
driven away to a building
where he owned two apartments and had on
occasion told his neighbours about his
plans to buy their apartments too
by 2015 wirecard now owned a bank in
munich
and was transacting millions of online
credit card payments
braun was the face of the company
speaking with investors
while his protege jan marcelic was
jetting around the world closing
business deals
many saw braun as a tech visionary
analysts and investors
truly believed that this was a new found
german
fintech version of steve jobs
they praised him as quote the innovative
spirit of wirecard
and a quote mastermind
however not everyone was believing the
hype
toby clothier head of mirrorboard
security strategy team recalls his
impressions of braun to the financial
times
quote the thing we found odd was his
obsession with certain words
his all-time favorite word was strong we
know
because we counted other favorites were
machine learning and ecosystem if you
are very gullible
then you might say he's a tech visionary
but if you look closer it was all
gobbledygook
end quote in 2017
braun had told investors that the latest
artificial intelligence was being used
to process
and analyze data in wirecard systems
however it's been reported by the
financial times
that behind the scenes wirecard staff
were merely using excel spreadsheets to
organize the information
another skeptic henrik lieber had met
braun at an event organized by goldman
sachs
upon asking about the strategy and
technology of his company
lieber received what to be considered
abstract and evasive answers
almost as if they were being pre-written
or being read out by a machine
hendrick knew that this was a bad sign
and his fund sold all of their wi-card
shares
several weeks after the pair met
from time to time braun liked to remind
people of his power
all coming from his seven percent share
in his company it's reported that braun
often checked the share price on his
phone and would give verbal blasts to
senior management if the price fell
demanding that they fix it he would even
take out large loans using the seven
percent share as collateral
so you can imagine how braun felt when
kpmg released a scathing report on
wirecard's financials in april of 2020
at a recorded town hall meeting braun
can be seen
fuming with rage but before we get to
this moment let's figure out how the
company got there
on the one hand you have 23 buy ratings
from analysts out of the 29 that i
counted on the bloomberg today
on the other hand there seems to be a
non-stop controversy coming from the
financial times
sirf and a number of other places that
create the kind of volatility i don't
think german investors are used to
why is that there's so much controversy
surrounding your company
i think we have a tremendous growth
development before us
we have big innovations before us so
this is what we concentrate on
uh i do not too much look into
controversies
but my message is i think we have a very
strong year before us
we concentrate on technology innovations
the first time that wirecard faced
scrutiny was back in 2008.
financial auditors from the firm ernst
young were called to review allegations
in the company's balance sheets
however strangely on this occasion the
two men that had blown the whistle
were prosecuted by german authorities
due to undisclosed stock positions
under the eyes of baffin the german
financial supervision authority
we saw the biggest stock market scandal
in recent german history and
as you have explained to your listeners
um buffon was more busy
with pursuing journalists who wrote
about the
dodgy business practices of wirecard the
reasoning was
these two men would write bad about
wirecard and then bet on the price going
down
before the news breaks in order to make
some money this is called short selling
it would be the same claims of short
selling that wirecard would use a decade
later to defend itself against claims
coming from investigative journalists at
the financial times
as y-card stock grew so did the
questions reports of financial
irregularities surfaced
and there were claims that the company's
operations were far smaller than what
they appeared on paper
it also seemed no matter how the economy
was doing wirecard was always thriving
in 2015 it was reported that there was a
250 million euro gap
in the company's balance sheet the
equivalent of three years of profit for
the company
wirecard dismissed this as short seller
backed propaganda
and analysts agreed
merely a year later in 2016 claims
surfaced again
that the company was involved in money
laundering again
wirecard denied all the allegations but
this drew investigations from both the
german financial watchdog
and private agencies then something
strange happened
over the next few years journalists and
short sellers who had spoken negatively
about wirecard's operations
began to systematically receive phishing
emails designed to compromise their
computers
however it hasn't been completely
verified that wirecard was responsible
[Music]
in 2018 the company pushed into the dax
30 index
this meant that wirecard became an
automatic stock in the portfolio of
countless german pension funds
they were now partnering with german
stores such as audi and almost a hundred
airlines
at their peak the company was worth 28
billion dollars
but it was the start of 2019 when things
started to escalate
there was an internal investigation at
wirecard singapore office
over fraud money had supposedly been
sent to india and back
in order to falsely increase the number
of transactions
this was to make it look like the
company was doing more business than it
actually was
in order to process payments in
countries where wirecard didn't have a
license
they would use third-party companies
some of these were in singapore
dubai but most importantly the
philippines
strangely the philippines office was
shared with a bus company
perhaps a sign that things weren't as
they seemed
[Music]
since wirecard didn't have an operating
license in these regions
the idea was that these foreign
companies would do the payment
processing for wirecard
and wirecard would receive a commission
this ended up being a huge part of
wirecard's business
pretty much all of its profit 1.9
billion euros or 2 billion us dollars
worth
investigators found that there was no
money coming into wirecard's munich bank
it was curious but wirecard explained it
away to the auditors
that there was actually a set of
accounts managed at two banks in the
philippines
so the investigators went to the
upon arriving to visit wirecard's
partner company in the philippines
the financial times reported having
found a retired man
and his family who was surprised to find
out that their home
was supposedly a branch of a
multinational company
at this point wirecard were furious and
sued the financial times for
quote misuse of trade secrets
a month later in a strange vote of
confidence softbank invested a further
900 million euros into wirecard
it just seems like softbank can't get a
break
i think softbank shares with us the
vision that the area of
digital payments in combination with
analytics artificial intelligence
innovative financial services on one
platform
is one of the most interesting growth
areas in the next 10 years
regardless towards the end of 2019 among
mounting investor pressure
wirecard appoints the accounting company
kpmg
to perform an audit it was going to
prove that all the allegations against
wirecard were groundless
six months later in early 2020 kpmg
reports it cannot verify quote the
lion's share
of wirecard's profits over the last two
years
wirecast ceo marcus braun vigorously
denied all claims of wrongdoing
and then in early june german police
raided the munich headquarters
what wirecard had claimed the whole time
was that they were using third parties
to process payments
these third parties would then give
wirecard a commission netting them two
billion dollars and the majority of
their profit
the reality was it all appears to be an
accounting sham
the two billion dollars wasn't in the
philippines
the banks that were supposed to be
holding the wirecard money told
investigators that they had no idea what
they were talking about
the bank stated that this money simply
didn't
no money none of wirecard's missing 2.1
billion
ever entered into the philippines and
we're hearing from wirecard itself that
they now believe that the 2.1 billion
probably does not exist now
as you may recall on friday bpi and bdo
the two top philippine banks
uh had but revealed that they did not
have any relationship with wirecard
and it is now indicated that the
documents that indicate the presence of
some funds in those banks were bogus
over the next week marcus braun resigns
and he's arrested shortly after
marcus brown has been arrested now this
is obviously a scandal that is becoming
or is deepening uh it is no longer
only about missing money wirecard is
saying that
potentially up to 1.9 billion euros
could be missing it's now also obviously
a
criminal investigation and one that is
serious enough for the prosecutors to
take this step
and actually arrest and detain the
former ceo
wirecard then makes a statement they
admit
that the money probably never existed in
the first place
shortly after they filed for insolvency
jan martileck wirecard's former chief
operating officer and marcus's
right-hand man has vanished german
newspapers report
that he fled to russia or belarus
there has been ripple effects from the
collapse german pensioners have lost
money
other payment companies owned by
wirecard were thrown into chaos
for example the firm pocket has had to
freeze funds for its uk clients
leaving some in danger of having no hot
water or gas
and with that that is the end of the
wirecard saga
it's how a company went from a small
startup to superstardom in the european
tech world
to losing 99 of its share price in just
over a week
the story raises questions of the
effectiveness of regulators
auditors rating agencies and financial
watchdogs who all let it happen
right under their noses was there
corruption involved to have this go on
for over a decade
perhaps time will tell when the
financial times was
starting to report about irregularities
when it comes to their accounting
and that was rebuffed violently by
wirecard but also the
german regulator didn't really look into
the matter thoroughly
and instead of it they actually looked
into whether the financial times
journalist has done its job
right so today and also already it
started yesterday there's a huge
discussion in germany whether or not
everybody was far too lenient on the
company
because nobody apparently looked really
into the business model neither the
regulator
nor also the analyst at some point in
time
one analyst from a very well-known bank
here in germany called the reporting
from the financial times fake news
apparently wirecard was always shielded
somewhat as the poster child
of being a tech company in germany which
we don't have too many of
while the story isn't over just yet it
seems like the company itself
might be thanks for watching
in case you missed the last episode on
the greatest phone failures in mobile
history
be sure to check that out a lot of
people were saying that they didn't see
it in their subscription box
i think it's fascinating some of the
crazy ideas and stories that happened
during the earlier days of the mobile
industry and lastly
a serious thank you to all of your
supportive comments on the very personal
video i made
before the last one i seriously wasn't
expecting it all
and it was very encouraging anyway if
you're new here and want to see anything
on science
technology business or history be sure
to subscribe to cold fusion
this has been to go go and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll catch you
again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Applause]
[Music]
it's me thinking
oh